[Music]
[Applause]
let's get to see all your beautiful
people tonight thanks for coming out how
many of you guys have been to event
before wrapped round of applause maybe
for those who have been alright alright
those who have not yet okay alright good
good okay cool cool so simulation is a
daily show and live event series that
features some of the greatest scientists
entrepreneurs and educators of our time
we aim build football stadiums with
thinkers and doers and intellectuals we
read and see if 22 guys in football pads
can do it why can't the curious
intellectual to do it right
all right let's do it let's do it let's
go all right I would love to just be
like our next guest needs so eventually
Jason Silva is an amazing super grateful
to have him join us today
he's a host of brain games he is the
host of shots of awe you guys love his
videos yeah filmmaker storyteller the
power let's bring out Jason Silva
[Applause]
Wow what's up guys
thank you for coming out appreciate
having you guys here
and thank you Alan for organizing this
I'm thrilled to be here with you hi it's
such a blessing to have this opportunity
to share conversation with you in front
of this amazing audience beautiful
people dude I'm honored I know at Jordan
Peterson and Michael Pollan recently so
I was just excited to try to follow in
the footsteps of those giants for your
series so thanks for having me I think
that you do you follow really well in
that in those footsteps and okay this is
life is all about you and not at all
about you we have this question that's
come up you made this amazing video
called existential bummer yeah yes have
you guys seen that video existential
bummer you know it's funny when I first
started doing shots of awe most of the
videos that I used to make were about
technology and futurism I had read
reycarts Welles book The Singularity is
near when humans transcend biology and
the sci-fi geek in me just got basically
an intellectual hard-on and what I mean
by that was that here was this grand
narrative whereby we would use our
creativity and our technology to
overcome our limitations and become as
gods right and that's what all of my
videos in the beginning were about and
this made me very popular in the TED
conference circles and people that were
into innovation and technology and
transhumanism started to eat up my
content which was beautiful eventually I
partnered with discovery digital
networks which came to me and said we
want to give you the resources to extend
these videos you're doing to explore all
different kinds of topic and from then
from there came the opportunity to I
guess explore different topics and I
think it was our first - our second
shoot we were in Amsterdam and I did a
video called existential bummer
which I think fundamentally
is to be honest the the worm at the core
the faint disquiet that haunts our
dreams and existential bummer was
inspired by the work of Ernest Becker
Ernest Becker wrote a Pulitzer
prize-winning book called the denial of
death in 1974 and this book was a
distillation of the human condition as
he saw it he was a cycle psychologist
and it kind of built on the Freudian
idea that our neurosis and our anxiety
stems from us being like sexually
repressed and Ernest Becker's ideas was
idea was that no our anxiety in our
existential conundrum is not only that
we're sexually repressed but it's that
we're repressing the most fundamental
horror of all which is that we are
mortal beings mortal beings who dream of
immortality I remember this professor
called Sheldon Solomon who was featured
in a documentary called flight from
death that put it quite succinctly he
said the explicit awareness that you're
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and ultimately no more
significant than a lizard or potato is
not especially uplifting this was this
was the worm at the core it's like no
matter what our aspirations no matter
what our dreams no matter how intense
our love affairs how highs our ecstasy's
like everything was sort of changed by
this anxiety about ephemerality about
transients and so existential bummer was
an exploration of that tension of that
disjoint 'men right it was like well
here are these cosmic beings that can
dream about the infinite right that can
ponder the infinite you know yet we're
housed in heart pumping breasts gasping
decaying bodies I mean it's like oh [ __ ]
that's where existential bummer came
from for me and it's a very personal
video and I think it resonated with a
lot of people because I think it may be
maybe it gave voice to something that we
all have felt but hadn't quite
articulated you know it's like when it's
you know you turn 20 years old or 25
years old it's your birthday you're
supposed to be celebrating but you start
to get like this
sadness about the fact that it's another
birthday and another trip around the Sun
and you know and or that feeling you get
when you stare at old photographs right
those sepia-toned photographs the aging
photographs it's what makes filters on
Instagram so poignant to make something
vintage to age it increases its
poignancy because it reminds you that
the moment has passed but it was a
transitory enchanted moment that is no
more and this like for me it's just like
it's annoying anxiety and I and I think
that whether we're aware of it or not I
think it's the worm at the core for a
lot of our mental distress and I think
existential bummer gave gave voice to
that yeah and there's things you do so
well at it is you speak with such
passion and articulation that you
observe the world in any form it's so
beautifully now thanks bro and okay so
you see this impermanence but you also
want to be creative and leave behind
something that is very impactful is that
shots of awe yeah very much so
so when I when I discovered the Ernest
Becker book it it kind of gave voice to
the sensation I was feeling and a little
pop-culture reference about that book
Woody Allen in the movie Annie Hall it's
a book that he buys for her in the
bookstore but now I love this and he's
like this is the book will explain why
I'm so neurotic and terrified the
universe is meaningless and so on and so
forth I believe in that same documentary
that I mentioned where Sheldon Solomon
speaks the the opening line is this idea
that we have emerged from nothing we
have a name we have consciousness of
self we have deep inner feeling we have
this excruciating inner yearning for
life and self-expression yet with all
this yet to die all right human beings
are in quite the predicament we have the
mental capacity to ponder the infinite
yet we're housed in heart pumping breath
gasping
body so we're gods and worms and so
essentially he he establishes the human
condition and then he maps the ways in
which we have dealt with the fire in the
belly and there's three historical ways
that we have placated death and put it
out of our minds the first one of course
is religion could it happen before
religion right religion was the first
antidote to the mortal coil you know if
you serve God you would go to heaven you
would experience salvation you you know
like follow these rules and you will
live forever in the kingdom of God I
mean it works you know and the problem
of course is that religion then gets
corrupted by humans and we use religion
to justify horrific acts against one
another and it's my religion against
your religion and these are like
immortality projects and we fight to the
death for our immortality projects and
of course you know with the Scientific
Revolution and increasingly secular
outlooks religion might be a pleasant
ritual and certainly Gothic cathedrals
and temples and synagogues can be
beautiful architectural masterpieces
that are a magis to the transcendent but
for those of us that don't aren't
convinced that following the scripture
will make us live forever we need
something else
to absolve us of our terror and so the
second way in which we placate mortality
is with the romantic solution to the
problem of death and the romantic
solution to the problem of death of
course you guys are well familiar with I
mean that's like Western civilization
and Shakespeare you know she's like the
wind she's my salvation she is the Sun
it's Romeo and Juliet it's the
deification of the other it's to find
somebody that you can worship that you
can elevate to godhood and that by
rubbing up against this sacred being you
will yourself be saved as well gets
reinforced by the movies and by the pop
songs and by the poetry and it's
beautiful to turn a human being into a
god or a goddess I mean in many ways we
are
gods and goddesses we were just happened
to be gods and goddesses that died but
we are gods and goddesses nonetheless
and so I think that again the romantic
solution is probably death solves that
problem temporarily because you know
it's like it's like that Jewish mystic
Martin Buber talks about I thou
relationships it's like when you truly
encounter another being to really see
another person as a cosmic being you
elevate them to this position of godhood
you temporarily enter an altered state
of consciousness and which time doesn't
exist I mean to be in love is to be
outside of time we didn't even achieve
that with someone we don't know by just
looking at their eyes and staying silent
for 15 30 seconds potentially yes we
glimpsed the infinite in the eyes of
another no doubt and a guy called Alan
Harrington in his book the immortal list
says during these moments we if you if
you think of life as like this people
mover like those airport people movers
and you know that we're all patiently
doing our thing and living our dramas
but the people whoever keeps going like
towards the ravine that is the end that
is the death of his mitigation of all
there is he says that when we're in love
the altered state of consciousness that
is occasioned by romantic rapture and
Rhapsody takes us out of the people
mover so now we get to co-mingle with
one another as gods outside of time now
I imagine anybody who's ever been in
love ever anybody who's ever lost
themselves in a beautiful song knows
this feeling very well we are absolved
from ourselves in the Rhapsody of love
the problem is it's a transitory
experience it occurs outside of time but
it's still bounded by time when both
ends I know that sounds like a
contradiction that's what seems to
happen it's like well I was outside of
time for three months with this person
now yeah that's life and and and then
what happens he says is that no
relationship can bear the burden of
godhood because the pressure of wanting
to be saved by a finite being puts a lot
of pressure our gods and goddesses
eventually reveal their clay feet right
and that is such a moment of despair and
or disappointment and it's [ __ ] up
because it
it comes with all kinds of guilt as well
like how could you be disappointed in
the one that you love because they
couldn't be who you needed them to be
it's like that Radiohead lyric that says
I wish I could be who you wanted you
know because it's a lot of pressure in
the honeymoon phase and the honeymoon
phase ends and biochemically we can't
sustain these states as long as we want
them to and so finally he says that
there's the third solution to the
problem of death is the creative
solution and the creative solution to
the problem of death might be called the
human Enterprise it's what we do with
that anxiety it's how we direct that
anxiety towards overcoming limitations
overcoming obstacles transcending
ourselves building building marvelous
jetliners and cathedrals and wireless
communication technologies and making
transcendent arts and making films and
creating virtual reality experiences and
concocting places like Burning Man where
we can actualize the human imagination I
mean the creative solution to the
problem of death in many ways is the
transcendence of the problem of death
because by many accounts we have become
a geological force in nature right like
if you look at the topography of any
modern city is something David Deutsch
talks about in the beginning of infinity
if you look at the topography of any
modern city like Manhattan or San
Francisco that physical topography is a
topography that is shaped more more by
mind and economics and intentionality
and culture than by geology so the
creative solution of the problem of
death is that our mind and our
collective efforts have now trumped
geology as a force in nature so that's
like our transcendence of mortality in a
way it's still symbolic ultimately
because everybody still dies but maybe
not for long
there's a lot of billionaires in Silicon
Valley working right now to overcome
death by reprogramming our genetics
which by the way will be the most
exciting thing ever once it spreads to
all of us host because at first right
the only accessible by a few people say
but regardless shout outs Aubrey de Grey
but ultimately Becker says that that
probably the creative solution to the
problem of death even if it's purely
symbolic even if it's purely
metaphorical even if it's just that you
wrote an amazing poem and
you kind of you know hurled yourself
into the abyss and realize that it's a
featherbed to quote McKenna like there
is a note that can be like the noble act
the creative act and that allows you to
sort of transcend your death
symbolically and he says it's probably
the the healthiest response to one
conundrum to live a life full of meaning
and full of purpose seems to be the
greatest antidote against this despair
that currently exists then is that
distributed evenly amongst people the
ability to be creative seems like so
many are trapped in the economic and
political machine well yeah I mean look
if you're hungry you can't be too
concerned about meaning if you've got to
pay the bills you got to pay the bills
but that goes back to the whole Abraham
Maslow and his hierarchy of needs I mean
all these questions of cosmological
significance
Aurra luxury at the end of the day
because it assumes that you were able to
feed yourself for breakfast and that
you're not dying of some horrific
physical ailment I mean certainly I
think in some ways that's why certain
parts of the world maybe that are less
wealthy actually report higher
incidences of life satisfaction and some
bizarre way and it's because you know
like you busy doing you thing going to
work and you don't have time to ask
these profound questions so certainly
don't have the toxicity of some of the
other things yeah but the point is I
think these questions are only going to
become more relevant because
technological advances and and
development across the world continues
to pull hundreds of millions of people
out of poverty all the time there's the
best emerging global middle class that
is becoming more aspirational and thus
is more concerned with with meaning or
increasingly will be in and eventually
happens when you get all the money what
happens when you get the one you love
then you realize that's it you know the
game is over actually
Jordan Peterson talks about that really
brilliantly he talks about the
importance of the noble aim and this is
something that really resonated with me
he says the noble aim is something that
you want to move
and you want to organize your life
around but you taint it because if you
attain it the game is over that's the
problem you want to be moving towards it
and always have it just beyond your
grasp
so that it Orient's you and it gives you
a map of meaning and it gives you a sort
of purpose and an orientation and a
compass so to speak but you know life is
not in getting what you want
life is about fighting for meaning and
it's a lesson that we seem to be
learning over and over and over again
and you got that toy in the toy store
you graduated from middle school when
you got that degree you got the job you
got the car it doesn't say she ate us
you know
then these are short-term goals and then
we get to the next goal maybe whatever
the long-term goal ends up being it is
to continuously be creative in the world
so maybe things like yeah automation and
AI whatever ends up happening in the
future will enable more people to be
creative over time
well the problem of meaning is not going
away right I think you have I've read
some reports they're like really
developed societies like in Scandinavia
and all these places where socioeconomic
anxiety is minimal and people it's very
yellow tearing society and people have
most of what they want they have all
these social cushions but nonetheless
the problem of suicide and all this kind
of stuff is really [ __ ] up and I think
that the problem meaning is gonna be
more and more even as we become
wealthier as a society potentially and
you know the guy eval no Harare yeah he
wrote sapiens and homeless day is
literally the best book he says how he
throws an article about finding meaning
in life in an age without work you know
because his prediction is that our worst
fears about technological automation
robbing us of our jobs but also of our
life purpose and meaning is a very real
thing
and now the on the optimistic front yes
increasing advances exponential advances
in technology and artificial
intelligence and all these things will
eventually create a world where people
don't have to work where the AIS will be
able to take care of most of what
everybody means but it's going to leave
all this empty space in people's lives
and so what are we gonna do to fill that
space you know and he says that we're
actually
gonna probably fill that space in video
games virtual reality virtual realities
yeah and but here's the thing here's the
thing he says that we already give
meaning to our lives with virtual
realities such as culture identity
religion you know your name I mean these
are these are not biological truths
these are cultural virtual realities and
nonetheless we use them to fill our
lives with meaning and purpose
supposedly so he predicts that in the
future virtual reality systems will be
fully immersive indistinguishable from
the real and we will be able to lose
ourselves in those worlds and undergo
the kind of mythological heroes journeys
that Joseph Campbell vividly writes
about or that our favorite films
beautifully map out I mean wouldn't you
want to be neo in the matrix and [ __ ]
rock it out or ever like I mean I think
that you're in an 80-year one right now
I mean oh what you're in an 80-year
virtual reality experiment right now
potentially if this is all a simulation
as your event postulates but then you
get to design your own virtual worlds
and you get to tweak and play with the
different variables and enter them and
look there's no doubt I think that um
the the tragedy of the human situation
is that we are these exquisite sensitive
thoughtful artists and poets you know
who have the capacity to imagine so much
and to dream so much and either a we
don't have the opportunity to express
that beauty that ecstasy that yearning
because of economic reasons but also
because of physiological reasons you
know maybe maybe you know you had to
work most of your life and then you got
an illness you know when you were 25 you
know you studied philosophy and that it
really puts you into a point of where
you were at when you were in your 20s
and other people don't study philosophy
and they're working lots of jobs and and
so that also makes potentially less
creative beings yes I mean I studied
philosophy because
it was I was lucky I had a mother who
was an artist who kind of encouraged me
to do what I loved I'm aware that that's
a privilege for sure yeah the more that
we can mold these minds into the world
to understand what you're teaching right
now about that essential bummer I think
more people will seek that creative
unleashing into the world I hope so okay
so we have this problem the among human
condition is problematic yes we live in
an age we live in an age of incredible
abundance incredible opportunity but
also increasingly high levels of despair
the burden and the gift of consciousness
is a double-edged sword right it gives
us this immense capacity to create and
to express ourselves and to do
everything we've done look how far we've
come look how fast we've gotten here at
the same time it makes us uniquely aware
that we are finite and we are limited
and I believe that the crisis of our age
is a crisis of meaning and I think that
that is the that is the source of high
rates of despair and anxiety and
depression and the high levels of
medication and we need an antidote to
the human Kanaan dream I would say and
that's that looking for that antidote is
what fuels my videos that's why I do
what I do my videos are like sort of
these verbal explorations of me trying
to work through you know my own you know
sort of my preoccupation with making
sense of things and finding a way
forward so that's that's where that's
the inspiration behind my work
existential bummer I guess is the
genesis of everything else everything
else is in response to the existential
bummer
and this is an amazing way to unleash
that creative potential through so you
okay so we say this is a crisis of
meaning it's a problem and you're
providing an antidote through shots of
awe what other antidotes do we have how
else can we explain this problem to make
it more relatable to people about how to
find the yeah so well one of the ways
that I think we can the
the diseases of depression and anxiety
are both characterized by excessive
rumination right our inability to get
out of our heads again the burden of
self-consciousness is that we're
thinkers but when thinking can also
become oppressive because in the face of
death we can be paralyzed to act you
know like to be fully naked and
trembling before the Kosmos is a scary
thing and so it can send us into these
loops of despair this excessive
rumination and self-consciousness which
characterizes anxiety and depression
anxiety is too much possibility and I'm
terrified I'm being torn apart you know
by fear and depression is the cave the
walls are caving in and I'm stuck in
this small reality and I can't transcend
it and so on and so forth but both of
them are characterized by excessive
rumination and self-consciousness and so
one of the ways out is to get out of our
heads and this is where for me I
discovered the power of flow States so
for those of you or not we're not
familiar with flow there's a book
written by a guy called chick send me hi
called beyond boredom and anxiety and
most of us oscillate for the most part
between these two states of mind boredom
and or anxiety and beyond these two
though is the state of consciousness
that many of us are familiar with even
though it tends to be fleeting and
finite but it's a state of consciousness
that is typically fills us with
incredible joy and Rhapsody and this is
a state of flow also known as the
runner's high also known as you know
being in the pockets if you're a jazz
musician being in the zone if you're an
athlete and Steven Kotler and Jamie Weil
who are the founders of the flow Genome
Project they describe flow as a state of
consciousness in which you feel your
best and you perform your best right so
think about that right it's a state of
mind in which you feel your very best so
your blissed-out but also your levels of
performance and whatever the task at
hand is the triggered flow go through
the roof so if you're a writer that's
like when you completely lose yourself
and you know five hours feels like two
minutes and you wrote the best thing
you've ever written in your life and you
feel amazing and you're energized and
you're pumped and it's like haha give me
some more of that
you know if you are a musician it's it's
when you go on some improvisational solo
and you just hear like you you had an
out-of-body experience and you were like
in the audience watching yourself and
you couldn't believe if you were doing
you know I certainly feel
hello sometimes when I do my videos and
that it just totally feels like I mean
the wordix Tacitus means to be beside
yourself to be outside yourself you know
so it really does feel like you've moved
out of your own way it reminds me of the
movie Black Swan you guys seen that
movie Black Swan it's a wonderful line
where the choreographer is telling her
you know the only thing standing in your
way is you
yeah you know that's a metaphor right
but it's a metaphor saying the only
thing standing in your way is the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex which is the
inner critic the inner Woody Allen
that's constantly self-doubting
everything and saying oh it's all for
nothing because we're all gonna grow old
and die one day oh it's all for nothing
you'll never make it oh it's all for
nothing cuz you're not good enough you
quiet that and then something else
emerges and more curious you and we're
open to you a more present you right and
people experience that as relief they
experience that as liberation and it
turns out that when you're in these
states pattern recognition goes up
lateral thinking goes up risk-taking
goes up so you find yourself doing
things in spite of yourself and that's
where all the good [ __ ] happens right
everything great because of the edge of
our comfort zone everything you want is
on the other side of fear I mean these
bumper stickers are there for a reason
and so you know I came across I mean I
had my own experiences of tapping into
flow it started probably in high school
where I consider myself very much an
introvert and I'm kind of in certain
situations that can be very shy other
situations that can be quite outgoing
but um I stumbled upon certain triggers
that would put me into the zone and my
thing has always been making videos I
used to make like short films with my
with my brother when we were kids and
always making videos I was obsessed with
videos my whole life and and what I
found was that when I entered what I
came to know eventually as a flow state
it felt to me basically as a I would
describe it it's just a poetic reverie
what I just like loosened up you know
and so it's like loosening the cognitive
loosening the mind loosening basically
shut down the part of the brain that was
like second-guessing it was like nah I
don't dance at parties no way there's
this stiff holding back part was pushed
aside and something else emerged and it
doesn't matter what triggers flow I mean
sometimes flow can be triggered from the
adrenaline of being on stage sometimes
flow can be triggered from the
excitement of something that just
beckons you know sometimes flow can be
triggered from breathing exercises jazz
musicians and freestyle rappers love
using cannabis
you know alegre california whatever
floats your boat truly but as long as it
gets you there and and what i you know i
didn't know that it was called flow at
the time but what i did realize is that
there was something ecstatic about
feeling in that state of mind because it
provided such a relief from the
incessant chatter that clearly i have to
deal with and so my you know there was
there was a feeling of grace and
gratitude when i found relief from my
rumination and my existential despair
and so then i decided that that has to
be what i build my life around and
eventually through you know research and
a lot of reading i came to learn all
about flow and the neurobiology of flow
and advances that are happening in the
psychology technology and neurobiology
and pharmacology of ecstatic flow states
there's an acronym to describe flow
called stir selflessness timelessness
effortlessness and richness so when
you're in flow your sense of self
vanishes that's the inner critic your
sense of time how time is regulated in
the brain gets shut down so time dilates
and the terror of the passing moment is
no longer there at least you're not
aware of it and finally finally richness
information richness you can have access
to more data because all the cul-de-sacs
and error messages of the rumination are
pushed aside so that's all you have to
remember stir self listen as
timelessness effortlessness and richness
and that's flow and of course whether
it's a surfer an athlete a musician
people who build their lives around
their flow report the highest
levels of life satisfaction so there's
something to that right so it's like you
know start with the the human condition
and the existential bummer and then we
figure out okay how can we address this
problem because you know we're here and
we might as well do something with our
lives and so for me it very quickly
became okay these experiences of flow
flow and the art that came from the flow
yeah because on the other side you know
whether flow is Kamiya every time I have
flow it's almost like a mystical
experience it's an experience of the
divine of the transcendent it's I call
it the aesthetic orgasm and and then and
then all the content that comes through
is usually in response to experience of
such rapture that it demands a response
you know so if people are looking to be
more creative in their life I would say
the question is not how to be more
creative the question is how to find so
much ecstasy in whatever it is it gives
you flow and then in the afterglow when
you come down from that experience
you're gonna be so you have so much
creative output to share with the world
that you won't know what to do with it
you know so there's a relationship
between mood regulation and creativity
and so I say you know flow has to do
with mood regulation has to do with like
tapping into that ecstasy of the present
moment and then and then seeing what
happens when you come out of that lots
of creativity for me
so definitely flow I would say has been
for me one of the one of the antidotes
to the human condom yes
flow being the antidote to the human
condom and then us being able to achieve
it in whatever way we find local Everett
were clever beings right we can start
figuring out like what works like what
works for each of us individually what
works for our children we birth in the
world we give them a lot of different
options and they figure themselves for
sure I mean if our educational systems
like we're built around what gives flow
to our students I'm sure that learning
and accelerate tremendously
what gives kill Rob our students Rob
have syntax about talks about that yeah
well I went to a Montessori School for
for elementary school and those schools
tend to build a curriculum around the
kids predisposition and interests what
do you think about this glowing
homeschooling unschooling
I don't know unschooling away from the K
through 12 system kid having a computer
when they're young we teach themselves
language teach themselves math or
science or history or our to create
whatever they want to explore and teach
themselves without any with maybe some
sort of mentorship or guidance as well
sounds interesting but what about the
social part and then the social part as
well as very important to some some kids
also don't have an interest as much in
the social part and they want to just
make we had we had the resources to
build a curriculum per kid you know a
unique educational profile per student
that would be awesome for sure I support
that aren't they doing something really
interesting in Finland have you heard of
this what is it in Finland the
educational system now I read is being
built not around subjects but around
problems to be solved and problems
become these projects require knowledge
in several different subjects to solve
the problem and so the students end up
learning you know about math they're
about science about environmental
studies whatever to solve the problem
we'll take this project basis but from
like elementary school that's great and
they're not showing the sort of the
highest levels of success in their
educational system yeah they're very
sophisticated it's great very excited
you're exciting future of Education and
also very exciting antidote that you're
discovering about finding meaning and
the flow States and also sharing that
with other people oh you needed water
should have noticed okay so in in
addressing this you found flow States
with yourself you found sharing flow
states are sharing how other people can
get into flow States I think a lot of us
have an inner critic within us that is
constantly combating with us don't do
it's meaningless etc and I think a lot
of us are finding that over time to be
this path of flow and of and it just
feels great at times it feels how do you
how do you handle the the times of you
know you don't have someone in your life
right now that you love right
you love your mother and yeah and but
you're not in a relationship so you you
know you've chosen to to not be in a
relationship right now
that love isn't the map right now for
you but the shop knows I'm definitely a
romantic and I I dive headfirst into it
knowing perfectly well it's gonna smash
my head or my heart at the end three bar
three years look so existential bummer
and then flow is one of the antidotes
romantic love is indulgence that you
have to have you have to rely I treat at
this point romantic love more like like
an aesthetic indulgence in other words
like I like the idea of somebody saving
me but it doesn't matter how many times
I'm disappointed in learning the same
lesson that you can't rely on another
person to be your everything there's
still something beautiful in the attempt
are tragic don't you think like there's
something there's something like
agonizingly beautiful about our efforts
did you guys have receive an illustrator
this guy I loved that movie a lot of
people didn't like it it was
misunderstood film but the whole premise
of that film if you guys remember the
ending is that this character met this
girl Tom Cruise meets Penelope Cruz only
once in the film you really only met her
like one night and then the rest of the
film we find out at the end was a
virtual reality construct created for
him after he kills himself and he gets
put into this like this nitrogen
freezing thing what do they call it
right Jenna
cryogenics and it's a cryo it's an
advanced cryogenic facility that feeds
you like a lucid dream while you sleep
until technology advances to bring you
back to life and in his lucid dream he
constructed an entire storyline and a
whole love affair where he ends up with
this person right and and the character
tells him at the end when he's finding
out what happened he's like you know you
barely knew her in your real life but in
your lucid dream she was your Savior
right you sculpted your lucid dream out
of the iconography of your youth you
know a movie you watch late at night
that showed you what love could be like
you know that spoke to me so vividly
because it just shows you how much like
these formative experiences that we have
as children right the or even as teens
you know music album covers movies they
create these archetypes in our minds and
archetypes of love archetypes of
transcendence archetypes of achievement
and then we spend our entire lives
trying to attain those that fantasy in
that wish fulfillment and so even if
it's a sort of even if we fail I think
it's it's it's the romantic part is in
the attempt you know even what you just
said right there putting flow before
love is a very important meaning is that
in itself is a very controversial I
think statement the problem is not
loving somebody the problem is the kind
of love that you think will save you
from mortality you know like that the
love that will save you the way you hope
that God will save you like the problem
is the desire for salvation but that's
also the most kind of beautiful thing
about us I think you know like we will
not go quietly into that good night we
will rage against the dying of the light
even if we end up dying we go kicking
and screaming you know we this refusal
of an unwillingness to seed you know
what to give up I think is kind of
beautiful and they don't need to be
contentious you can find flow and then
also find love and super happy in life
okay how about
what is this okay so what about the
Buddhist perspective on things the
meditative perspective that I'm in
permanent totally cool I'm just going to
you know enjoy the time that I have
rather than the rate you just work no no
look I think I think the philosophy of
none of non-attachment
look I'm not an expert on Buddhism my
limited understanding though has to do
with not holding onto things and
embracing a philosophy of non attachment
as attachment is supposed to be bound to
the ego and if you try and send the ego
and you don't have attachment you suffer
less yeah and my intuition is you suffer
less but you also feel less you love
less you desire less you agonize
beautifully less you express yourself
intentionally less interesting and so I
think that the you know the the art that
moves me is the art that arrests me is
the art that transform is the art that
pains me is the art that that gives me a
nine feeling in my stomach like III like
the push and pull the ecstasy and the
agony I think it's what makes us us I
think it's romantic
maybe I'm slightly masochistic but I I
am incompatible with the idea of
non-attachment you know when I look at
my family people that I love friendships
that I love places that I love like I
love those places and those people so
much it hurts right the music that I
love sometimes I listen to a song I love
the song so much and I'll get sad from
just the thought that I don't have
eternity with which to listen to this
song for you know like I watched a film
like Inception and I'm just like oh my
god I just wished it that I could watch
this film like once a week for the next
million years you know like I just
there's just I get off cognitively from
from arts from ideas and from beings
that that the idea that the whole notion
of just letting that go is just
incongruent to me but to each his own
right it can there can there be a
feeling of ecstasy
with with medicines with meditative
feelings as well of not attaching to
that feeling of ecstasy but you tell me
I don't know either I've made a video of
every insight I've ever had because I
didn't want to just let it go if I would
have it along attached to the I thought
I was just like you know meditation
sometimes tells us you know watch your
thoughts but don't you know don't be
attached to them
certainly some thoughts are not useful
to attach yourself to but every video
that I made started with the thought
every video started with a thought I did
not let go of yes it was a thought I
became obsessed with I wanted to make
sense of it I wanted to tile it with
language sharing and and making the
video was a kind of psychological
exorcism and it was only through the act
of making the video that I finally was
at peace and could let it go but see now
I haven't let it go now it's a thing
that exists forever in tangible form so
it's my battle against ephemerality my
all art is a battle against ephemerality
so I don't know I mean there's
non-attachment thing I don't get it I
think it's a way to placate ourselves
against the fear of death is what I
think it's a deathless rationalization
but in in the face of no other choice
you know the may be the healthiest
response is to find some noble
acceptance
like oh well it's God's will for this
person to die a horrific death of cancer
God's will you know it's what God God
wanted I just I don't buy it I think
it's a fricking tragedy
I think illness is a tragedy I think
death is a tragedy you know and we also
don't know what happens after death well
hey I'm sort of envious of people who
are convinced of an afterlife I'm
envious for their peace while they're
alive but I just you know I can't
convince myself doesn't mean that I
can't be agnostic but being agnostic
doesn't doesn't rid me of
you know the despair associated with
infinite nothing okay so if you do get
to live longer and you we have this era
of transhumanism of approaching us what
do you enjoy the moment of every five of
those moments you have to record it
there's a guy called David Pierce he
wrote this whole online essay called the
hedonistic imperative I don't know if
you guys are familiar with the
hedonistic imperative but he basically
advocates for an engineering of a
technological approach to engineering to
radically extend human lifespan and
eliminate diseases and eliminate
suffering he has this whole idea called
Paradise Engineering and the abolition
of suffering and he basically says it's
like let's do a collective human project
like putting a man on the moon to
eliminate human suffering from culture
yeah but not just not just you know the
physical suffering of people but like
the suffering caused by disease the
suffering caused by aging the suffering
caused by mental illness he himself says
that the MDMA like state of
consciousness is a model for the perfect
human state the problem is that MDMA is
in taking too much too much can be sort
of toxic even though it's amazing for
psychotherapy it's not something you can
do every day but he envisions advances
in biotechnology and psychopharmacology
to eventually reprogram the mind you
know at the level of neurons and
neurotransmitters to engender a new
baseline and the new baseline was for
something more similar to an MDMA like
state is what he sets the new baseline
yeah yeah and well if there are some
people that have there's a there's a
there's a syndrome called Williams
syndrome they sometimes call it cocktail
party syndrome and it's actually very
similar to the MDMA like state the
problem is these people are so trusting
and so loving with perfect strangers
that they can be taken advantage of yeah
yeah so everybody has to be on the same
vibe in order for it not to be
potentially dangerous for the person who
has it but the point is the you know
we there's a lot of different modalities
of consciousness that are possible so
many altered states of consciousness
mediated by different types of drugs
hint at the different possibilities for
phenomenology this is just but one of
millions this is the one that has been
selected for in this kind of Darwinian
competitive survival based guarded
vigilant modality that we need right now
to always plan for the future and
prepare for the worst and so on and so
forth that's been selected for but maybe
that's not what we need in the future
you know maybe in the future a eyes take
care of everything and human beings hang
out and make art and the kind of
consciousness that is required is one
that facilitates being in the present
Michael Pollan in his book new book how
to change your mind he talks about the
psychotherapeutic benefits of
psychedelics you know in in therapeutic
settings to address the pathologies of
anxiety and depression and the book
starts out with this idea that's
fascinating he says that the human brain
as it exists now is like an artificial
intelligence program it takes in data
from the present and compares it with
data from the past and uses that to make
predictions about the future so we're
like an artificial intelligence program
making predictions the brain is a
prediction machine and so what that
creates is essentially a sense of
impatience with lived life a perpetual a
DD and living life in a kind of constant
future tense
he says the funny line is the the good
news is I'm seldom surprised the bad
news is I'm seldom surprised right
because you're always predicting the
future you're always sort of a little
bit vigilant not quite present because
always on the thing on to the next thing
and so the good news isn't you know
nothing ever catches you off-guard in a
bad way but equally bad is the news that
nothing ever causes you catches you
off-guard in a good way you're never
surprised you never delighted he always
kind of jaded the been there isn't done
that's of the adult mind and so and so
then he says one of the things that
commends travel beauty and certain kinds
of drugs is precisely the fact that they
block all signals forwards and backwards
so here you are tweaking the way the
baseline works and by blocking all
signals forwards and backwards
backwards memory right and forwards is
pre modeling the future you get rid of
those signals and you're hurled and
spent at the we call the astounding
frontier of the present a present that
is literally wonder full wonder being
precisely the byproduct of that
unencumbered sense of first sight the
childlike wonder the virginal noticing
of a sense a world that is characterized
with poetic Rhapsody and inspiration and
awe and how has all these cognitive
benefits I mean eyes would it be if we
could reprogram ourselves so that our
baseline was William Blake right to see
the world in a grain of sand and heaven
in a wild flower and hold infinity in
the palm of our hands and eternity in an
hour I mean don't you want to live in
that state don't you want to live inside
of a poem don't you want to live inside
of a pop song it's possible right it's
just we have to get our [ __ ] [ __ ]
together
right we have to fix things we have to
get rid of inequality economic
inequality we have to deal with people
who are homeless and dying and suffering
on the street we have to address the
grand challenges of humanity which we
could already do today if we just had
the will and then eventually the
technologies to do these things are
advancing exponentially exponential
right there are weeks there are there
are decades where nothing happens and
there are weeks when decades happen
exponential is weeks when decades happen
so the progress that we are already
seeing is astounding and directed
towards the right things we could
address the Grand Challenges of humanity
and then we can turn our minds and
ourselves into the ultimate engineering
project to tweak ourselves into blissful
mind-body States where we could
essentially be gods in a utopia beyond
time and that sounds to me like a
project worth creating going for yeah
right
that's a boy can dream we get some
little yeah we this is good asking Q&A
as well we will be right there in a
couple minutes so so the the stopping
and smelling the Rose is I mean when
you're on the beach really loving the
shells and the rocks there's so many of
these amazing examples when you when you
when you look at your mother look at her
like it was the first time you looked at
her your partner just that that state of
not looking at the past and not like a
future being right there it yeah I mean
some of the some of the greatest moments
that a child has are precisely because
he's unencumbered by responsibility you
know like we also organize our society
in a way that doesn't permit us to be
very present right you got a hustle and
you know you got to be in an anxious
state to get ahead you know and we've
inherited that from the anxious states
of being ahead you know when we lived in
the savannahs of Africa we had to be one
step ahead of the Predators and now we
have to be one step ahead of our
competitors it's the same thing but you
know don't you
it's it's it's that even a blade of
grass becomes a magnificent world in
itself have given proper attention like
if we if we were freed from the
constraints burdening that limited
Faculty of our attention maybe we could
redirect it towards just the miracle of
being alive right consciousness itself
could be more indulgent upon its
capacities to contemplate you know I
often them I'm like a quote or order
yeah but the reason for that you know my
mother's a teacher and she's taught for
40 years high school literature and in
her classroom walls
she always had beautiful quotes written
like really big all over the walls right
and granted that's literature but
English class is really the class that
teaches you how to be a human being
right
Masterclass there's numbers on the walls
and chemistry class there's chemistry
equations on the walls in English class
you have beautiful quotes that tell you
how to be a better person on the wall
mines are like parachutes they only
function when open practice random
kindness and senseless acts of beauty
like these are the courses around the
wall and so I I think I kind of acquired
that same impulse to surround myself by
the ideas that point the way constantly
right the wallpaper of my mind is filled
with quotes that are like post-it notes
that remind me about the states of
subjective well-being that I want to
live inside of yeah
so wonder in awe are huge ones for me I
and so I collect a lot of quotes about
that and obviously there's a lot of
cognitive benefits of being in a state
of awe and wonder there's a lot there
was an essay that I read one is called
the death of awe in the age of awesome
and Henry wise Meyer wrote it you guys
to look up the piece it's great but he
talks about out or f scott Fitzgerald
writing about wonder he says that wonder
is a transitory enchanted moment in
which man must have held his breath
compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation he neither understood nor
desired face to face was something can
measure it this capacity for wonder let
me think about that when was the last
time you were face to face with
something can measure it to your
capacity for wonder when was the last
time that you completely eclipsed the
bin there's and done that of the adult
mind that you were freed from the tedium
of the daily and thrust into the
numinous like when was the last time you
had a religious experience as a secular
person and what I mean by that it was an
experience that carried you outside
yourself an exhilarating neuro storm of
such intellectual pleasure such
cognitive ecstasy that you basically had
a mind gasm right anesthetic orgasm and
that that that's healing experiences
they experiences these experiences make
us whole and these experiences make us
holy what was the Stanford studying on
benefits oh so yeah this is this is one
of those examples of like
science validating something we know
intuitively um Stanford and Berkeley in
other places did these studies on the
subject of awe and if you've seen my
videos you know that this is something I
cite repeatedly but basically uh is an
experience described as one of such
perceptual vastness right such
perceptual expansion that the mental
models of the world that you usually
rely upon to categorize things as
happening to you it's the bid there's
and done that's at the adult - like oh
yeah that's a light oh yeah that's a
person yeah yeah I've seen those kinds
of shirts before oh yeah it's just
another sunset right but occasionally
you encounter something that's not in
your maps as of now those maps you've
built throughout your life to categorize
and put things into order you encounter
something that doesn't fit into those
maps and it can be something that's
genuinely outside those maps or you
could be in an altered state of
consciousness that makes you see
something that was already in the maps
but you're seeing it from a vastly
different vantage point either/or
the point is that during those
experiences you have to now accommodate
yourself enter into a new relationship
with this thing and in that act right he
calls it the dialectical pattern of
reconcilable estrangement this is David
lensing google it but it's creating you
know the experience offers a distance
between this thing and you and then your
new relationship with it closes that
distance and that act we experience
subjectively as ah this particular
Rhapsody is are inspiring paralyzing
opie ated adjacency where you're cracked
open and the light gets in like Leonard
Cohen says right like these moments of
off I mean they're they're awesome but
they they're not just pleasurable in
that moment but like I said before they
heal us because after the fact the
studies found people report increased
feelings of well-being increased
feelings of compassion increased
feelings of creativity and yeah those
three oh and the experience acts as an
anti-inflammatory
so it has all these like markers in your
body it's it's good for you so all will
bring us closer together as everything
bro like the people the people the
people in the in the studies about all
we're in Berkeley and Stanford but then
the studies that are coming out now
treating people with PTSD anxiety and
depression with psychedelics the stuff
from Johns Hopkins University in the
Imperial College of London that Michael
Pollan wrote about in this new book
these studies say that the healing takes
place only when people experience a
mystical experience while under these
molecules and if you look at the
hallmarks if you fill the questionnaire
that William James questionnaire of a
mystical experience all of the
attributes mimic or mirror the
experience of all that I was just
talking about before a feeling of the
sacred a feeling of communion with the
cosmos the feelings of infinite
connection with other human beings a
feeling of well-being feeling of noetic
truth of ultimate reality being revealed
right so mystical experience is mediated
by psychedelics treating people who are
sick from depression and anxiety with
treatment resistance right it's a more
mystical experience the more they report
the healing weeks and months afterwards
same with people who experience aw that
doesn't necessarily have to be mediated
by psychedelics it can be the birth of a
child that could be seeing the Grand
Canyon for the first time you can see
making love to somebody new it can be
traveling yeah the whole point is that
we need to pay more attention to what
happens to us that is so healing during
these moments that arson so you know
economically nonuseful
yeah right right you know you could
obsess with that flower it's not
bringing you a thousand dollars no yeah
that's but that's what's so interesting
yes oh so it's like we're so obsessed
with productivity now and we encourage
the use of substances that promote
productivity like caffeine and readily
but I think we're gonna have to stay pay
start paying more attention to these
other domains of mind the ecstatic
domains and then I'm not the only person
saying is by any means I mean this is
what Michael Pollan talked about in his
book this is what the book stealing fire
that day me
Steven Kotler wrote that was also a
best-seller we need to pay more
attention to the ecstatic and
increasingly as we give up our jobs to
automation in the future which is
happening we're gonna have more wouldn't
have to find more creative and hopefully
more joyous ways to fill our time is it
better to find The Ecstatic in things
that are not necessarily mundane so
rather than finding its ecstatic moments
in the mundane can we craft things that
are not yet discovered by humans and
that be our ecstasy is there one that's
better I mean it for me the ultimate one
would be something like the end of the
movie contact like if we were able to
make a portal to the other end of the
galaxy and the witness celestial events
outside of space and time and talk to
aliens that would be pretty
awe-inspiring one of my favorite lines
about that movie is precisely when she
says they should have sent a poet
they should have sent ya Carl Sagan but
yeah man I mean that's what we need to
we need to start doing that like
journeys without and journeys within
right let's go explore the solar system
and let's like create virtual reality
engines in combination with new and Theo
genic molecules and explore the inner
solar system - like I'm more interested
in what's next
in terms of that like what's the next
baseline what's the next base line L so
what's the next what's the next level of
like immersive art like what happens
when it is of theater meets VR meets
like maybe certain molecules that make
you more suggestible and and and
facilitate the suspension of disbelief
you know and and that because you know
this the sky's the limit I think in
terms of the future of art within this
art 500 years ago we saw Michelangelo
take years to sculpt Statue of David
years to make the Sistine Chapel with
500 years later we are so heavily
addicted to instant gratification
are we gonna how do you see us
transcending that you're talking about
the consequences of increasingly limited
attention spans because we're always
getting hit with like the next dopamine
hit on the top of our social media we
used to spend years making of one piece
of art and what well he did well a lot
of a lot of people did there you have
tapestries paintings sculptures filled
or things used to take years yeah I mean
I guess the consequence that now
everybody can be can participate in the
global conversation whether it's by
writing or publishing or making art
means everybody has access but it also
means there's more noise and more
mediocrity yes everybody's a
Michelangelo so that's always that's
like the trade-off right everybody has a
voice but a lot of like not interesting
voices crowd your feed so that you
barely ever see anything magnificent
anymore but everybody has a voice that's
the high noise so maybe maybe maybe I
don't know maybe they're there that's
maybe the role of curation and maybe
there happens to be a new focus on
excellence yes you know and that's that
can be how we transcend it yeah short
term addictions that we have cake as you
were talking about the cosmic
perspective we do like to ask a couple
questions on the show do you think we
are alone in the cosmos have you guys
heard of the trance engine hypothesis no
okay
so it's a good theory to account for
Fermi's paradox Fermi's paradox is the
one that says that given the size of the
universe of even the observable universe
and given the preconditions that
potentially are there for life how come
we see no evidence of intelligent life
right we found all these like planets
all these things in the habitable zone
and then you just infer the rest using
some mathematical equations about scale
and you're like wow there there should
be plenty of advanced civilizations and
yet we see no evidence of it that's
Fermi's paradox right there should be
but there isn't and so the transaction
this is an answer to that paradox and
basically it says the following if you
look at our own evolution and our
technological advancement it goes in two
directions it goes outward as we spread
across the planet and make massive
cities and make airplanes and then make
rockets and go to the moon like there's
this outward expansion of our
technological scaffolding right like a
spider's web like spreading out
potentially into the universe yet
simultaneously there's this in a word
expansion as we make denser and denser
computational substrates right the chips
keep getting more powerful the
processing capacity gets more powerful
and infinitely smaller until you
eventually might get to what he calls
femto scale computing which is computing
that's like computational density that's
on the on the size of it like black hole
like dimensions of computational density
okay and the idea being is we have this
outward expansion but then we have this
much faster exponential inward expansion
and no doubt eventually maybe a couple
hundred years whatever we're gonna live
in virtual realities because that's just
what gonna happen synthetic artificial
intelligences that can think and
essentially have personhood will live
inside of these virtual realms inside of
femto scale density computational
substrates so we're gonna basically open
up a virtual universe that's operating
in dimensions that are smaller than the
more dense than a black hole so we will
disappear out of space and time out of
the visible universe through these so
scaled and and so transection is
basically that we disappear into into an
outside of space and time and that's
when we find all the other advanced
civilizations so they they went in
instead of out mm-hmm that's transection
that's a real thing coined by a guy
called John smart you can google it I
made a video about why we don't why we
don't we haven't found the aliens I
certainly don't believe any of the
ripple
sorts of flying saucers or anything like
that those sound more like psychedelic
delusions that's a really good one
though transection hypothesis that's a
really interesting okay and then do you
think we're already in a simulation I'm
gonna read a passage to answer that on
Latian hypothesis like whether we're in
a simulation right now like I just think
it can be argued either way but one of
the things that um you just argued for
transition hypothesis yeah yeah but but
listen to this so um
Kevin Kelley talks about he started
Wired magazine he talks about a series
of discontinuities that have changed how
we see ourselves in the cosmos the first
one was when we thought we were the
center of the universe and then we
realized we're just a little speck of
dust in a sunbeam and then and then
another discontinuity has been the one
that we think that we're like somehow
special and the other animals are not
like gods and they're not and then we
realized evolution though we're the same
we're on a continuity so the
discontinuity was was eliminated again
the third one that we're going through
now is that we think ourselves as
different from the man-made or the
human-made so there's the natural the
organic and the human-made is somehow
unnatural but increasingly we realized
that we're just smack in the middle
between the born and the made and that's
another continuum in the Technium which
is the Kevin Kelley phrase for the
organism that we call technology he
calls the seventh kingdom of life so
technology is we realize is just
continuous with biological evolution but
then the last exceptionalism and it goes
into this idea of whether we're in a
situation or not v discontinuity is the
special status that we give to the
physical we feel the universe to be a
place physical material that pushes back
and presses and presses against us
things have weight size and duration
that's what the universe is an everyday
experience the real stuff that can be
measured felt and sensed our world of
matter and energy follows a set of laws
to such an exact
the degree that we can manipulate it to
make rockets and computers that's pretty
solid matters consistent refusal to be
bullied outside of its own laws adds to
the sense of it being real right real
means physical right information on the
other hand lacks physicality
unlike energy which we can at least
measure with physical instruments a
digital bit is disembodied it weighs
nothing it takes up no space we don't
have good measures for information we
are not yet sure if the total amount of
information in the universe is conserved
nor if it is finite yet we have come to
see that life even our own life is a
pattern of intangible information rather
than material form evolution that great
engine of creation is a pattern of
information and mind especially the mind
is a type of information flow so we know
that the most powerful forces in the
universe that we are aware of are
constructed of the most intangible
things we can detect bits there stands
the discontinuity atoms vs. bits but
lately physicists have become to suspect
that atoms themselves are composed of
information in some way that we don't
understand as the legendary physicist
John Wheeler puts it it's our bits the
deeper we inspect the interior of
subatomic particles and their quirky
behavior the more they can be explained
as information flows many physicists
expect that when we get to the bottom of
how matter works
we'll find primarily a structure of
information and the absence of anything
material atoms will be understood as
elaborate dynamic arrangements of
intangible signals solid-state
physicists David Merman writes matter
acts but there are no actors behind the
actions the verbs are verbing all by
themselves without a need to introduce
nouns actions act upon other actions
there's no duality between the existence
of a thing
and its properties properties are all
there is indeed there are no things as
this discontinuity between the realm and
of the physical and the realm of the
immaterial is erased
scientists have began to re-envision the
laws of physics as complex algorithms of
code energy also is being restated in
terms of information the pulsating stars
and iron planets will gradually be seen
by science as wisps of intangible
nothings organisms and technologies
including mega structures like
skyscrapers and starships and floating
cities will be defined as structures of
computation equivalent to software so if
that's the case yeah then yeah yeah
really happy that you read that Jason
last question and we'll open up for Q&A
last question is what he thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world
whoo so I recently uh I underwent an
experience of psycholytic therapy which
is with a nurse who has a degree in
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy to
take care of me um to address some
related issues that I had with anxiety
you know I deal and one of the things
that I that came to mind during that
time was that the most not just when
something is beautiful but the sensation
that it occasions right the feeling of
beholding beauty right is the most
exquisite and important thing in the
world and by the way that's a big
umbrella term you can include love under
beauty can including aesthetic
experiences under beauty but but I just
think that to me the most beautiful
thing in the world is the cognitive and
aesthetic orgasm which is the moment in
which you commune with something
magnificent beyond yourself
so it's a moment of revealed truth and
ecstasy and merger and communion and
it's when you cry not from sadness but
from ecstasy right
why does beauty make us cry ask Alain de
Botton and he says it's because what it
hints at is the exception and so there's
this cognitive dissonance between what
you're seeing and what you know the
average to be and in order to correct
that imbalance you cry it fixes the the
discontinuity there and that's called
catharsis I love you know but but you
know you can be you can have an
experience like watching a film and a
film builds up slowly and magnificently
or a melody might do and you know it
works - have you heard George Peterson
talk about music and how it speaks
meaning to people it's the one thing
that cynical people can't be cynical
about and I feel the same way about
about good films you know they're they
speak meaning they broadcast meaning you
know and and you know we're meaning is
like oxygen for us you guys know that
line that says you know human being can
live for you know a week without food
three or four days without water but
can't live for a minute without hope
right people commit suicide when they
lose hope meaning is the antidote to
hopelessness meaning and significant you
know is is everything and and so the
capacity of music and cinema to to the
way it delivers meaning to us the way it
patterns it you know like like
melodically and then like spoon feeds it
to us you know is almost tantric in a
cognitive way you know it's it's it's to
me it's everything and and and to
regularly submit you talked about
surrender
the ecstatic surrender to a work of art
to a work of meaning I think is the the
greatest possible indulgence that we can
give ourselves amidst the cosmic tragedy
of being finite beings who dream of
immortality so that's like the temporary
fix until the singularity makes us all
immortal and saves us so yeah what a
wonderful conversation Jason just super
blessed I've had you in San Francisco
I've been here we all greatly appreciate
you and love your work so much and we
hope to hope to see you again very soon
thanks bro
thank you take some questions you an a
now